un des patients de plus en plus jeunes
sans co morbidité et qui développent des
formes sévères c'est le profil de la
lettre que le professeur moussa seydi
poirier sévère du jeu dans ces services
de mélodies ambitieuse on voit plus de
cas graves chez les sujets jeunes qu'on
a envoyés au début de la pandémie
les jeunes se relâchent beaucoup plus
parce que se sentant plus en sécurité
il ya un grand nombre de figures de la
lutte contre l'épidémie au sénégal ou
l'infectiologue qui a été le premier à
expérimenter l'hydroxyde chloroquine
construites et les maladies nautisme se
dit prêt à faire face si la situation
des tons purs et nous sommes tous dans
nos enfants poser problème c'est faux
les malades pour les étudiants pour les
chercheurs mais il insiste sur un
élément
la vaccination reste le nerf de la
guerre la commune ne l'aura esclaves
sommes vraiment libre non vous retrouvez
notre ville notamment pour retrouver
notre liberté
il faut plusieurs mesures c'est vrai
mais l'une des mesures phare c'est la
vaccination
on ne peut même pas comparer les risques
liés à la vaccination les risques liés à
la maladie
il n'y a pas de comparaison possible
prenons l'exemple de thrombose dont on
parle il y a l'internaute et 425 mille
fois plus de cas de thrombose chez les
patients atteints de colite que chez les
patients qui ont reçu leur vaccin
un discours qui a encore du mal à passer
auprès de la population sénégalaise en
moins de cinq mois
quelque 165 mille doses
été administrés sur une population de
près de 17 millions d'habitants
méfiance scepticisme alimenté par des
questionnements légitimes ou les rumeurs
les plus folles comme en europe et les
risques potentiels liés aux dalcin ont
donné un coup d'arrêt de campagne de
vaccination au début de la vaccination
j'ai entendu que certaines personnes qui
se sont fait vacciner on fait des avc et
d'autres en sont décédées c'est à cause
de tout ce que j'ai entendu aussi parce
que je n'ai aucune maladie chronique que
je pense que pour moi il n'y a pas lieu
de se précipiter pour se faire vacciner
[Musique]
ce que l'état veut nous imposer c'est
trop difficile
enfermé la population alors qu'on a déjà
pas les moyens de s'acheter à boire et à
manger avec la crise qu'on a au sénégal
c'est trop difficile
si on nous rajoute encore d'autres
obligations ça va être trop dur nous
sommes une population excédée par
plusieurs mois de restrictions mais qui
commence progressivement à changer
d'avis comme le note le personnel
soignant dans ce centre de santé dans le
quartier de yoff en laisserait au mois
de mars
beaucoup de cas de refus par rapport aux
vaccinations donc on va est pratiquement
personne mais là on
avec sont donné le mot donc
et par rapport aux personnes qui sont
revenues déjà on a noté moins de cas
d'effets secondaires dans ce pirate
froid sur cette opération
une prise de conscience qui est sur le
point de provoquer un autre problème
disposer de suffisamment de stock pour
répondre à la demande
l'objectif du sénégal dac signer au
moins 20% de sa population d'ici la fin
de la